Beyonce and jay-z aired their dirty
laundry
decoding the carter's surprise album and
we're also with Chris Pratt and all the
stars at the MTV Movie and TV Awards
Plus how Jersey Shore will be part of
the situation's wedding hey this is the
daily Denny I'm Denny and guys I was
busy enjoying my weekend brunching like
you do on Saturday when Beyonce jay-z
decided to just drop their joint album
as if I wasn't gonna cancel all my plans
leave brunch early and download a free
subscription of title because I did
exactly that
all right guys yes the carters unleashed
their 9 track LP love is everything and
a ridiculously stunning video over the
weekend and simply put the couple go in
and then they go off to help break down
some of the biggest Carter revelations
I've got my fellow bee hive member she's
buzzing in now Courtney doesn't know oh
hello I'm happy to know I wasn't the
only one that made a new email account
final so true no shame was exclusively
our title where were you and everything
is love dropped in what did you think
guys I was taking a nap and for some
reason my Beyonce senses were buzzing
and I snapped up and an album drops a
double job you text me to action line
and I saw something literally bumping
into it like in my bedroom um I love to
go cuz they put everything on blast on
this one didn't they everything all out
there like what so they talked about
their cheating scans brigadiere family
frenemies
even their loved chawla Gatien which
jay-z shuts down and heard about us
Billie Jean in his prime for the
thousand time to kidney mine online they
call me dad kiddingly you're not
supposed to take his dad thing literally
that's too famous all right so that was
a really good one but another revelation
comes from mr. Carter in action one of
my favorites apparently he turns down
performing at the Super Bowl halftime
show
I said no to the Super Bowl you need me
I don't eat you every night we in the
end zone
tell the NFL when your stadium - man all
right all tea no shade but I'm not sure
Jake could turn out a Super Bowl
halftime show like Beyonce you know I
mean I agree I'm just saying oh by the
way could we talk about the video for
ape [ __ ] I mean only this powerhouse
couple could shut down the Louvre in
Paris like what I mean they love Paris I
kinda I get it that's like their place
to be but you're right oh the whole
thing was a piece of art that should be
up in the Louvre I'm sure they're gonna
plan on a loop everything all right a
masterpiece well clearly guys Queen B
and J are holding core and showing
things that they are a united front
despite their marital issues which be
drags her husband for in the couple's
most honest song
[Music]
[Music]
that was the one Courtney text me about
school did you hear that did you hear it
I mean it's real that's real real but
also like a hold him back though not
holding back but also it's the one I
find myself going back to I mean that
right there I think is a good good
picture of this album you don't know
mean I think you got your front but
they're also being really honest with
their fans in themselves which is great
after all that they've been through but
listen there's a song friends which fans
are suggesting might be referencing
jay-z and Beyonce missing Kim and
Kanye's wedding ain't going to nobody
nut
me and my wife Fifi don't camp the house
of fire don't believe all right so the
only reason why I think they could
actually be talking about Kanye here is
you guys will remember easyto
Charlamagne tha God that he was hurt J&B
didn't come to the wedding even though
he knew they were going through some
stuff I mean you can't be so hard on him
I completely understand but yeah Kanye
said if you're family you're not gonna
miss a wedding except here's the thing
their wedding was literally in two
different countries they get a pass I
think so I'm not married but if your
partner is going through something I
would be so the last thing that you
would want to do at a wedding it's be
together with a little let alone on the
trip I'm fine I agree with you there
seriously well guys we're just
scratching the surface there are nine
songs on that EP but to get our beyonce
fix even more the carter's dropped a
bonus track salud
that has everyone buzzy buzzing Courtney
says it might be the song of the summer
I think so you guys have to take a
listen you're about to go listen to
right now I am oh we have got to stick
together
all right thanks Cory meanwhile guys
this past weekend et was with all the
stars at the MTV Movie and TV Awards
which air tonight at 9:00 p.m. on MTV
and that's where we also caught up with
Beyonce protégées Chloe and Halle after
the surprise album drop it's a buzzing
about BAE and J's new album everything
is love did you guys know about that
said you heard it already
tell us everything you
we love this album we're just so happy
for them and we can't wait to join them
on tour this summer yep it's gonna be
awesome it's gonna be so much fun I love
them they killed it the first time you
heard the album what were your thoughts
what was your instant reaction well we
heard it just like everyone else did you
know I think it's super special they
hold their art close to their hearts and
I loved it yeah pre Fame I mean we had
three Fame that's the genesis that's the
Big Bang you can see it coming out of my
head and golden locks who is your
Hollywood writer die oh my gosh my
writer died the Jersey Shore cast also
hit the awards show but our Katie Krauss
sat down with them and Mike the
situation was in the middle of it
wedding planning
the big question is will the Jersey
Shore be part of his big day you're
engaged talk to me about the proposal
episode that's the next one that we're
gonna see um you know I always dreamed
of doing a proposal on Jersey Shore but
for years we didn't have Jersey Shore so
when it came back to the forefront
everyone was going I was like you know
what I'm gonna do it and finally I was
able to do it my best friends were all
there we did it in such a big way
I actually just seen the incoming
attractions for it and it is so dope I'm
so excited for everyone to see it and
it's just really cool are you in wedding
planning mode right now we are in the
beginning steps of the wedding planner
okay what are three wedding must-haves
I just started doing the cake testing
okay looking
a number of venues in different
locations but so far the the best you
know thing has been the cake testing
have you chosen a best man is it gonna
be someone in this room I haven't chosen
a best man yet but that day is coming
soon
well that was like a yeah yeah I'm gonna
someone sit some of these guys down very
soon like I gotta get our information
out of you it has to be there right how
do you guys feel about that are you
gonna be DJ the one a man is gonna be
there I don't expect him to DJ but
obviously he will jump on your body well
yeah you don't have to work at your
wedding exactly whatever Mike told us
that he's still working out on whether
the wedding will be on TV so we shall
see all right we have more with the
Jersey Shore cast now on e t--
online.com and thanks for watching guys
make sure you're subscribed and all of
that and tomorrow you're celebrating the
one-year anniversary of the daily Jenny
[Music]